[Music]
Ingrid's so nice to see you thank you
for coming out here to talk to me today
my pleasure thanks very much for doing
this we're gonna try to be an antidote
to our sound bite culture and we have
all the time in the world to go as deep
and as long as you'd like to go that
sounds very good and very unusual yeah
well right much needed in in in this
culture right we've lost our ability to
have mature conversations with nuance
that's right there's no depth to things
anymore although I enjoyed you on on
Bill Maher recently that was fine oh
he's so kind he really is he's the first
person I've ever heard the only person
I've ever heard say that his dogs are
the only ones who greet him as if he's
the Beatles when he comes you know he's
he's one of those people that I think he
has a version to humankind in a certain
way he does but he also lets people he
disagrees with speak their piece of
course and then he argues honestly which
is something I very much respect a man
with him because he hears the arguments
out so he's not sort of a rush limbaugh
way he's very opinionated and he only
has people who agree with him on his
show he has the gamut yeah he does it's
always fun when he's jousting with
somebody that he doesn't agree with but
he's on board with everything that
you've been doing for ages and ages he's
on our he's a member of our board he's
our oh he's an honorary board member yes
and he has been he was one of the very
first if not the first so he has a big
heart for animals yeah
well congratulations on the new book
animal kind thank you it's a lovely read
I found it to be it wasn't what I was
expecting it's just kind of like this
rumination on the beauty and complexity
of animals of all species if I can I'll
read thee which I have to read actually
I can't really remember it the subtitle
because that's integral to it is
remarkable dis animal kind remarkable
discoveries about animals and
revolutionary new ways to show them
compassion because you're right
did want to open people's eyes to who
animals are and all their abilities
their talents their emotions the complex
way the ways they communicate just
anything and everything and you pick up
so much information it's hard to figure
out what's not only interesting but
relevant to how we treat them and the
second part of the book is learning how
to treat them perhaps better than we
have been right you've divided it into
two parts the first part is kind of this
exploration of the unique talents of a
variety of species and rather than
answer pom all anthropomorphize these
animals you really look at what makes
them unique and special and and in many
in so many ways more talented more
intelligent than human beings you know
that the kind of underlying theme of the
whole thing is historically we've looked
at the animal kingdom along this linear
spectrum of intelligence and capability
right and this really up ends that by
saying the more we learn the more we
realize that it doesn't work that way
that almost every single animal has
something about them that makes them not
just more adapted to their environment
but but talented in ways and in
capacities that humans lack so there's
an argument to be made that their
intelligence exceeds that of our own in
in so many ways and in countless ways
actually yeah you're right I mean we
have and I go into this in the book
we've had really pathetic ways to
determine animal intelligence because we
set the standard at human intelligence
which is one intelligence among many and
you know the animals the other animals
may not be able to make a nuclear
warheads that might be a really good
thing they may not pollute the rivers
with chemicals from leather tanneries
you know hats off to them right so
that's what our intelligence has fought
about I mean other things too we have
anesthetics we have all sorts of things
because we're so creative but I always
think the average human being take me I
couldn't make a cell phone I
couldn't make an aircraft I just use
those things I use this technology so
even the average human can't be judged
by what humankind has come up with so
the book animal kind is to say look
we're all animals it's a great Orchestra
of life if you will but human
intelligence is not the gauge because
animals as you say they have
extraordinary talents that far out due
from sense of smell eyesight a homing
instinct feeling seismic waves before an
earthquake happens for goodness sake
knowing that a tsunami is coming
elephants in Thailand trying to break
the chains and run before anybody else
knew it was happening but all the ways
that they have devised to deal with our
world because we have taken over their
world it's now our world you know it
shouldn't be answerable morphism either
as you said it's not as if humans are
alone in having certain emotions like
love and fear and loneliness and grief
all that's a shared emotion all there's
a shared emotions so there is now and I
go into this in the book this um we've
come from the great chain of being which
is where early mostly Christians or if
maybe exclusively Christians decided God
was at the top and then there were
angels then there were bishops their
lower kings and queens for intelligence
all the way down to peasants and under
peasants believe it or not actors and
then under them stones I mean under them
snakes and reptiles aha ugly snake is
kind of at the bottom right because it's
a place in the biblical canon exactly
and so it was all very religious and
that's how we graded animal life and
animal intelligence and from that we
have come to is this thing now called
the mirror test which scientists have
used for some years
see how intelligent animals are and that
is can they recognize themselves in a
mirror
now tribal peoples have sometimes failed
this test I should point out but they
don't mention that because a tribal
person might see their mirror image and
think it's someone attacking them and
attack the mirror so chimpanzees
everybody says oh yes of course they
pass it because they're primates like us
they are highly intelligent we like
chimpanzees but this little fish called
the wrath who's about the size of my
finger has also passed it she can
recognize herself in the mirror and
start preening and then luckily she can
take selfies but yes she's passed the
test so I think it's what we don't know
right about animal intelligence well
most people are familiar with the
complexity of you know a dolphins
language or that of the whales and and
we're aware of the Micra Tory habits of
many species of birds but there's a lot
of sort of new examples that I'd never
heard of in this book that are pretty
mind-blowing I mean what are some of
your favorite you know most kind of
impressive there are so many you know
rich I collect information about animals
but in the research for this book I
learned a lot I didn't know there is a
moth who actually communicates with
iridescent and you have to be aligned
you probably have to be another math but
you have to be aligned in such a way
with their wings that you can see how
the light catches them to know what
they're communicating and of course
cuttlefish I didn't know this can
communicate with patterns of light and
waves on one side of their body to say
flirt with another cuttlefish mm-hmm and
not show that at all on the other side
where they might be showing anger or
being fierce against another cuttlefish
that they want to stay away but we have
tree frogs drum out their messages on
bark and we have actually city frogs now
that use drainpipes to amplify their
sound because hue
sounds and cities are now so loud right
you talk about that with birds and how
they have to strain their voices now in
order to get their calls heard and
received and get up earlier because our
rush hour gets earlier and Russia is
more din and so the birds are getting up
earlier so they can hear each other
before humans take it over right you
even go so far as to talk about slime
molds all the way down to the single
celled animals I think I put in slime
molds because to me it's startling that
a slime mold can actually navigate a
maze and a slime mold has some way of
for lack of a better word thinking about
things working things out that makes us
surely stop in our tracks and think if a
slime mold can figure something out
I'd better not shortchange the others
because you said you know we know a lot
about say how Birds navigate by the
stars by low-frequency radio waves that
we didn't even know existed at all
sensing like the magnetism of the poles
yes like this the Earth's magnetic field
they they are absorbing that using it
using it to navigation to think about
things but we don't actually act on that
we think oh that's interesting and
that's why the second part of animal
kind was so important to me because it
says hang on a minute
if you've learned all these phenomenal
jaw-dropping or inspiring things about
animals then it's got to inform your
behavior you can't just go that's
interesting and move on and continue to
disrespect them or not give them credit
or think of them as those those others
you know yeah I think and you make that
point very plainly and clearly but it's
such a difficult sort of gap to to
bridge in the sense that it's it's not
necessarily about the information
the information is important and the
more that you can inform and educate
people about the you know the nuances of
intelligence and the emotional lives of
these animals and the ability that they
have to communicate and all of that but
what is really required to move the
needle in terms of people's behavior you
know if it was just information we would
have solved this problem a long time ago
a good point
and obviously with the environment if it
was just information we would have
solved that a long time any nut or pick
your subject yeah there has to be
sometimes a threat or some almost
cataclysmic occurrence that shakes us up
it usually takes some big thing that
happens that makes you think oh this
could impact me today I do believe
people have woken up at least a lot of
people have woken up to the
environmental threat but they are trying
to wangle their way around it's like do
I really have to make these changes how
many changes do I have to make so in
animal kind I point out that eating
animals for example and it should be
enough to just say good god I'm a
civilized person I think I'm a kind
person I'm not going to put money into
the slaughterhouse or transportation of
these animals in law but it's not enough
as you say you need to think well what
about my grandchildren then or what if I
fly less or the new thing now is plastic
straws you know great ok don't use a
plastic straw let's see let's start with
not eating the fish I'm such a good
person I'm not using a plastic straws
that's great
well I'm eating my fish sandwich yeah
and you'd look at the trash in the ocean
most of it isn't plastic straws it's
mostly discarded fishing gear it's those
big trawling Nets it's other things
whales now we have off the coast of
California even who are being weighed
down by crab traps I mean do you really
have to eat a crab is it that important
to you to eat a fish
you know just leave it be and sir couple
that with your straw so I do think
you're right people are people need a
jolt and so I try to give them the
amazing things about animals for their
sympathy for their empathy for their
understanding but yes at the end of the
day most people need to have a flood an
earthquake invite the end of the world
right it has to be educational lives I
mean people are inherently I believe
empathetic and live their lives you know
in that manner but I think the further
the greater distance there is between a
decision that's made and the kind of
impact of that decision the more
difficult it is to change the behavior
so for example with plastic straws like
wedding that to the environmental you
know downstream impact of that is so
distant from the choice of whether
you're going to put a straw in your cup
at Starbucks that it's hard to you know
it's hard to get people to change
I think the food that is on our plate is
a little bit more direct because you see
the animal product and you can
understand that something had to be
killed for that but still you're not the
person doing the slaughtering right or
if you're wearing a leather belt or
whatever it is it's easy to sort of
remain myopic to that but the closer I
think education is you know goes a long
way towards wetting those things
together so that people can do their own
inherent math and realize the downstream
impact of the choices that were we're
making but but it's tricky I mean you
spent your whole life you know on this
on this issue and I gotta say on some
level you've got a it's got to be
incredibly gratifying to see how far
this movement has come since you got
into this and 1970s yeah we weren't an
overnight success I can tell you that
you know all social movements and that's
something that actually gives me hope
is I not only look at how a society has
changed I mean when we were starting
1980 we were pioneers believe it or not
things like soy powder you had to buy in
a coop if you could find it mix it with
water by hand or with a whiz
and now you go to the supermarket and
you stare for 10 minutes thinking do I
want the macadamia or the you know it's
just ridiculous
so yes how far we've come but all social
movements go through the same thing you
know ridicule discussion acceptance and
I think we've come quite a long way but
yeah I'm not necessarily gratified it so
much as I try to be optimistic because I
can only be hopeful looking back of how
far we've come and people who are in
their 20s today I mean this is like the
feminist movement you have no idea with
women's rights how far we have come with
everything civil rights how far we have
come much much further to go
right so the foots not coming off the
gas not at all no you can pry my dead
fingers from well let's take it back I
mean you were born in England but you
were really raised in New Delhi right is
that where you spent your formative
years well India my parents were in New
Delhi and I was shunted away to a hill
station boarding schools because it's
too hot in Delhi in the summer and so
yes I was raised by nuns in the Hills
which is why I'm allergic to nuns today
I can only imagine but your mom worked
with Mother Teresa she did and when I
went home for the holidays was an
orphanage in New Delhi there was one in
Calcutta and we used to pack pills for
lepers we used to stuff toys for the
kids we used to go over and play with
them and all that kind of stuff but she
also took in animals she always said to
me it doesn't matter who suffers but
that they suffer and if there's
something you can do about it shake a
leg
well your real interest in in in animal
suffering and animal rights wouldn't
come until much later about obviously
that that's a powerful seed that was
planted early I always you know how some
people are drawn to art I don't
understand art at all
but I always was drawn to animals and so
it wasn't later it was at that time in
childhood I was the one saying Oh mommy
look
there's somebody beating a bull by the
side of the road or oh look there's a
dog in that drainage ditch and I always
had that hmm did you have personal
interactions with Mother Teresa
I didn't I never met her you do no never
met her at all my mother did but I
didn't yeah she weren't with her
directly at times yes and there were
lots of volunteers mostly expatriates
who are over with free time and were
able to help with charities in India so
my mother was big on unwed mothers she
looked after that because they were
ostracized cast out in society and
children she always loved children and
animals too but yeah lepers that looked
a lot so you take your your fine
Catholic private school upbringing and
somehow find your way to Maryland at
some point I did it was a circuitous
route but I actually married somebody in
in Europe who was American and we came
back to the u.s. to live and I was
studying for the brokerage I was going
to be a stockbroker it's there's
something very comical about that
well I it's even stupider because I've
always loved math and I thought I wanted
to be a pure mathematician but I also
wanted to travel a lot in my youth and
so I thought well what's numbers
oh all right I'll become a stockbroker
so I was busy doing that when somebody
moved away next door to me and left all
these kittens behind I don't know two
dozen or something and I thought Oh
moved out in life just moved out and I
thought oh I need to take them to
somewhere that looks after them looked
up in the phone book we didn't have
Google then found the nearest animal
shelter put them in my VW bus drove them
to the shelter and it I was just
astounded this was the United States of
America it was filthy it was harsh they
put the kittens down immediately when
they took them into the back room I was
stunned went into the kennel and they
were
the dogs who are confused and all those
childhood feelings of caring about
animals came rushing back to me
and I thought I'm not a stockbroker I
need to care about animals and I applied
for a job in the kennel it was it was
really that crystal clear that moment oh
it was I hate injustice and there's
nothing that gets me more upset than
people bullying and they were bullying
those animals in that place and I
thought I have to work here mm-hmm and
how long did you work there well I
worked there and I blew the whistle on
them so I was chucked out I went out on
my ear I went to the council and I
worked hard and got the people in charge
of that shelter thrown out is that how
you got into a law enforcement then it
is I then became a cruelty
investigations officer and started I
then went to sheriff's rippy school for
the police department to learn how to
prosecute cases and that's what I did
what was the state of that department at
the time of the cruelty investigation
yeah I mean what was good I mean just
I'm trying to get a sense of kind of
what the perspective was in terms of
enforcing anything you know against this
kind of behavior
it was pretty pathetic it still is in
some jurisdictions and we still have to
fight hard at Peter to get prosecutors
to take some cases seriously but back
then it was almost non-existent I read
the law in the state of Maryland all
these laws are written for laypeople to
understand they're not complicated and
you have to divide them by the elements
and I thought we need to use this so I
went and met with the state's attorney
and I made my case I got deputized I had
a law enforcement background then
because I decided I needed to be trained
and I began to bring prosecutions and
the judges I found in most cases were
completely sympathetic many of them had
a dog or a horse or something and they
didn't like what they were hearing and
so they cracked down on the people who
are starving or beating or whatever they
were doing to animals right Wow so when
does when how is PETA born out of the
well from there I was asked to go and
clean up what was then the DC dog pound
the Washington DC dog pound and I had
some friends who were in government who
advocated for me and I became the first
lay pound master which I thought was a
really butch title I liked it very much
and I went and took over the DC what is
now animal shelter and put in place the
first spay and neuter clinic that there
was and made sure that no longer could
universities come waltzing in to our
place and pick take their pick of the
animals and use them in experiments
which is what was going on and no longer
could dog fighters and people who wanted
a guard dog just come in plunk five
dollars on the table and take out some
big aggressive dog so I tried to change
all that and pretty much did made it
into a fine place had wonderful help and
bequeathed it to the Washington Humane
Society to run and then while I was
doing that formed People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals because I read
Peter singers book Animal Liberation and
thought oh good grief you shouldn't just
be being kind to animals within the
context of using them there are the
nations there just like us we are
animals we need to stop seeing them as
hamburgers and handbags and tools for
research we need to see them as other
individuals and treat them with respect
leave them in peace so it changed my
whole perspective yeah that book has had
such a profound impact on so many people
and and culture at large it's still as
relevant today as it as it ever was
oh it's a terrific book because he takes
you back to the anti-slavery movement
for example and said you know some
people said well we'll always have
slaves because they're stoic they don't
cry out in pain you can do all these
things
to them they're not as intelligent and
as congressman Dellums said once on
Capitol Hill when they were hearing a
bill about animals
he said if you took the words slave out
of an old congressional appeal a hearing
and put in the word animal or you did
the same here put in Slavin you would
have the same arguments being made by
those who wish to continue to exploit
whomever they wish to exploit so you can
I mean I didn't grow up with the same
kind of prejudice I grew up with the Raj
with British people thinking that they
were so superior to Indians
my father would clap his hands and
somebody would come running to see what
he wanted
you know we people look down on Indians
Indian immigrants to the United Kingdom
were treated very very badly I grew up
with that I formed the first Beatles fan
club in school in India and it was a
convent and Mother Superior came into
our Hall where we were all gathered and
said stand
Ingrid ward that was my name then she
said I understand that you have started
a fan club for the Beatles do you know
that they come from a slum and that was
it the worst thing you could say you
know working-class people were
denigrated as if they were stupid Know
Nothings and so I translate this to
animal rights and think you know not of
what you speak
and hence animal kind this is who they
are you are not a God as a human being
and they are not trash you know they are
feeling emotional complex intelligences
and yet you have them in Chains in cages
you're hitting them with a Bullock or a
whip you are throwing things down their
throats to test your medicines and
cosmetics hands off just the same way we
now understand with certain other human
beings yeah
at this time other than Peter singers
book there I mean there was no animal
rights movement so to speak
there was nothing I think not even the
word vegan you know vegan was a person
from Las Vegas or from the planet some
Vegas or something no animal rights
wasn't even a concept until Peter Singer
put it into the vernacular and not even
the vernacular it was just floating
about and we had the first animal rights
conference because before that they used
to be health vegetarian conferences that
was it it was all about laxatives and
living longer so we had the first animal
rights conference and we talked them
about can we show you what you're not
being shown by advertisers it's not a
happy little pig in an apron dancing his
way to your sandwich or barbecue you
know this is what they're doing they're
notching their ears they're cutting off
their tails they're castrating them no
painkiller and people were stunned we
said look we've been inside a laboratory
we went inside that silver spring right
right I want to talk about that and this
is what we found it's not a few animals
being treated well because they may hold
the cure to saving a baby you know it's
just wanton abuse neglect disregard for
them and nobody is looking at better
ways if you just want to be more
efficient
forget the animals from it people aren't
putting the money into where we could be
more efficient for our own selfish sakes
so we changed the conversation and we
uttered the word vegan and we acted the
words are animal rights in that first
conference people must have thought you
were bananas back then now oh yeah
many people did and we were mocked we
had a demonstration in Washington
against a chicken slaughterhouse and it
made because it was so weird that anyone
would care about a chicken in 1980 it
made the front page of the Washington
Post it was on every
radio station I worked for the
government at the time and I remember
being listening to the radio and no
matter what station you tuned in it was
there are people protesting chicken
slaughter like what the hell are these
people doing is that when you realize
the power of the media I mean you you're
no stranger to knowing how to grab
headlines now you're a master
provocateur well we have to be I mean
you know it's just you want to reach the
most people that you can hmm and
obviously leafletting on the street one
pamphlet at a time we still do and it's
what you get back then it was what you
could do there was no internet you know
but we did learn and back then as you
mentioned earlier people were more
willing to discuss things in death so we
could make the case of who animals are
and why we need to look for other ways
instead of just abusing them making them
suffer you think that it's harder to do
that now oh it's much harder today it's
sex it's conflict it's politics of
course I mean who can avoid that right
now yeah well you're the crazy chicken
lady in 1980 but Peter really you know
got on the map by virtue of this Silver
Spring monkey case right so walk us
through that because that was really
that really set in motion a lot of
change it did and that again made the
front page of the Washington Post it
also made 60 minutes in Australia it
made the whole run of press that there
was to be had I think why it struck a
nerve is that most people had been sold
a bill of goods and they did believe
that oh it's not so many animals and
they must be treated okay that
researchers had perpetuated made sure
that they said we're scientists don't
question us and in fact they would say
that quite openly who are you to
question us we're scientists they were
above the law and we were able to show
by going into this one laboratory and
showing videos actually was film at that
point and photographs mostly photographs
and getting expert opinions of the
hideous condition that these seven
monkeys were kept in tiny cages rusted
wires breaking their fingers off because
their backs had been operated on and
they didn't have that much nerve
sensation in their arms being just left
in these tiny boxes in a room being
given electric shocks in a converted
refrigerator having their testicles
squeezed with pliers to see if they felt
all these things we were able to bring
it out into the light of public opinion
put it on the news go in with a search
warrant bring the animals out and for
the first time people thought good god
I've been able to see inside it's not
like we've been told at all right and we
got bags of mail sacks of mail from all
over the country saying how can I help
which are truly the most magic words the
words I love to hear today was that the
first time that anybody had sort of
covertly photographed what goes on kind
of behind closed doors with animal
before that there had been two other
situations in New York where somebody
had leaked films leaked photographs of
monkeys being used in space exploration
tests pre space exploration tests and
the other at the New York Museum of
Natural History and they were both very
awful but they hadn't circulated because
nobody had really been able to do
anything there had been a protest
outside the History Museum but with this
we had primatologists anthropologists
veterinarians from all over who we took
into the lab at night and showed them
the conditions showed them the monkeys
with festering wounds showed them
everything and they filled out expert
statements and with those expert
statements in the photographic
photographic evidence we were able to
get a search warrant that was the first
time and that made it all break open
hmm so images ended up on the front page
of The Washington Post
I guess yeah and it becomes like a huge
deal right Supreme Court case and
ultimately
culminates in the passing of the Animal
Welfare Act in 1985 right the amendments
to it there was already thanks to the
Animal Welfare Institute the there had
been 1996 or 1976 I can tremana there
was the animal there must be 17 1976
there was an animal welfare Act
nobody was enforcing it which the Silver
Spring monkeys case made crystal clear
and there was no interrelationship
between the people who gave the money
say the National Institutes of Health
the biggest funder of animal experiments
in the world and the so-called
inspecting body the United States
Department of Agriculture where the
inspector came maybe once every year two
years sat in the front office had a cup
of coffee asked the experimenter if
everything was okay and left without
even looking at the animal so these
things really were made possible to
understand through the silver spring
monkeys case and what was the specific
issue that was before the High Court
well what it happened was the lower
court had found the experimenter guilty
a jury trial on several counts he then
appealed and we went to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court sent it back
custody of the animals was actually the
issue sent it back to the lower court to
rule so this thrust you into the
limelight and in a pretty big way it did
we were amateurs we didn't know what we
were doing really accepting how many
people were working but there were five
of us as the core and there might have
been a few dozen who had come out I
remember Reagan was elected and there
was a big parade in Washington and we
went out with a banner it was all very
patriotic looking stars and stripes and
red white and blue and it was that old
Frank Sinatra song take back your mink
take back your pearls and we had changed
the lyrics and people had seen that on
national television because the parade
was being televised and one of the
people
main announcers had actually summit
thinking it was just a patriotic song
realizing it was the first-ever animal
rights song and although these people
started to get in touch with us to say
yeah I don't wear fur I don't want to
wear fur and yes I don't want to exploit
animals how can I help so altogether yes
and weird at what point like do you do
you make this conscious decision about
the strategy that you're gonna deploy
like you're nothing if not like
controversial for a lot of these kind of
you know various forms of protests over
the years that grab headlines but also
really ruffle a lot of feathers do and
make people angry
well we always say you know I'm not here
necessarily to make friends we'd like to
yeah well we're still talking about
these things right and that's in no
small part due to the you know the edgy
nature of how you staged these events
we'd like to make sure it's
conversational so people might put us
down and in the old days certainly that
was par for the course these people say
have you seen what those Peter people
are doing but they'd say it at a dinner
conversation and then everyone would
talk about it and I think people would
say well yeah I mean they're crazy but
and then they talk about the issue you
know I don't like what's happening to
animals prefer for example or so on
we try to be provocative because I mean
what's the point someone on our staff
said it's like a car crash if Peter is
doing it you have to look if you don't
want to all the way up through you know
every it seems like every year I don't
know if you did it this year but you'll
tape some some public service
announcement type television commercial
with the intention of you know saying
this is our Super Bowl commercial and
then creating additional press out of
the fact that it gets rejected because
no networks ever gonna air we'd be
delighted if they ever did and one of
our commercials on the Super Bowl and we
do have a couple of donors who said if
they ever do we will we'll we'll give
you the money but no they don't air it
and we go in knowingly
probably aren't going to this year we
did a fabulous one it's still it's I
don't know if I can convey this you have
to look at it it's on peta.org it's a
bee who is humming the national anthem
and floating is all animated floating
around and visits or flies over all
these other animals there's a bear a
deer a fox a fish who take a knee oh I
did see this yeah it makes me cry every
time I see it I have to tell you I'm a
sentimentalist but I think it's just
beautiful and at the end it says you
know every living being deserves respect
and of course Lisa lounge who is in our
office is the creative person behind
sitting right over there
former podcast guest - hi Lisa she went
to an agency they crafted it so
beautifully it's perfect and we then
Lisa I went to colin kaepernick and said
i is this alright with you the concept
and he said yes and so because we didn't
wish to be disrespectful in any way we
wished to show he's a vegan mm-hmm we're
all in this together respect should be
for everyone doesn't really matter who
you identify with like it's not just for
me as a woman women's rights there's a
principle right not just you because
you're whatever you are race religion
age it's because there's a principle
discrimination is wrong bullying is
wrong respects is everything looking out
for the other guy and he said great so
we put it up NFL stepped in apparently
they went to Fox I mean you know they
don't like anything to do with it and so
you think that involves taking a knee
thing in so many ways but over four
million people have watched it right
away and it's still going strong on the
Internet
yeah and and and as provocative as
anything you've ever done I would think
you know in a different way now in a
more kind of like subtle way I suppose
and my sense is that like looking at the
movement and you have a
solution of the movement from 10,000
feet there was a moment in time where in
order to get people's attention you
would have to do these crazy things just
to get people to even consider the issue
you know that that that's beneath that
but the movement has matured to such a
point where there is adequate mainstream
awareness about what's going on at least
on some level and and as such the
tactics have to evolve as well like it's
it's not necessary to kind of do some of
those things you were doing in the 80s
and 90s anymore in fact it might be
counterproductive there's a more you
know kind of a different tactic that you
can take now in order to provoke the
discussion I think what people don't
know about Peter is that we have an
enormous corporate negotiations arm
we're behind the scenes and we always
have been but it gets bigger behind the
scenes talking to retailers and others
who use animals in exploitive waste
caused them a lot of pain and suffering
but actually while we no longer have to
crawl with our hands and legs and steel
traps for example outside stores
although Canada Goose is certainly still
catching coyotes and steel traps and
stuffing geese in to slaughter crates
fur is dead it really is that was our
slogan it's happened none of the big
houses Gucci Galliano Donovan Versace
none of them have fare anymore however
that said and we are not mainstream in
other ways because we have become
mainstream which we have to be careful
about with with eating animals but we
still have things to do because we've
been in every sheep shearing shed try to
say that quickly in on every continent
except Antarctica and in every single
shed we have found things that would
turn people's stomachs about the way
wool is taken from the sheep I mean
sheep being bashed in the face being
I've seen those videos it's horrible and
more people should leather you know I've
been back to India followed the cattle
trail people are amazed
is that India exports so much leather
there are major leather exporter leather
isn't environmentally friendly it's full
of you know decomposition toxins and
what-have-you but the cruelty of the
cows is extreme so we still so ironic
beyond idea
well you look at also you know the cow
is sacred mother cow Nandi the bull is
sacred and he's pulling these over
loaded sugarcane carts you have Ganesh
the elephant who is sacred who is in
Chains for life in a temple going blind
in with trumpets in his ears and wedding
parades it's like anything you know
Christians say don't cheat on your wife
if they say don't steal but yes that's
fine people do but no we now have
demonstrations outside fashion shows
where our people are taking this odd
mixture it's charcoal and syrup I think
it makes some grungy mess pouring it
black muck pouring it on their heads and
faces and appearing in photographs
around the world to say please leather
is cruel it's environmentally unsound
get away from that - it's just carcass
it's the bigger profit part of
slaughtering a cow if you're vegetarian
you're supporting the meat industry by
buying it yeah and there is so much
innovation happening right now in terms
of new textiles you know it's
interesting to kind of you know watch
that evolve I feel like the food space
is a little bit further down the line in
comparison to what's going on in apparel
and and garments but it's changing
quickly
oh it's phenomenal and in animal kind I
talk about that as one of the things
that you can do is you just sometimes
don't realize it but if you look we now
have you want to look chic or trendy or
my god or if you want to be warmer than
if you were wearing polo real fleece or
fur
we have Apple leather grape fruit
leather pineapple leather you name it
I just saw out of Mexico this coming
cactus leather any phenomenal things
Nike has a range of shoes now made of
ash and I think Nike Reebok has a range
of sports shoes made of trash I know I
just saw that Nikes releasing this new
shoe that's completely made out of
completely recycled garbage and recycled
fishing net so back to if you want to
save the oceans you know you can save
the ocean save the cows save the planet
all in ones one go with fashion how does
it go like if you're gonna approach
Michael Kors or Ralph Lauren or any of
these you know big houses and you're
having this back door kind of
negotiation with them what does that
look like it's actually pretty simple
is that we ask for a meeting and we
start at the top and we see who we get
and often we will get the buyers and we
will get the decision-makers and we will
show them you will go to Milan or
wherever it is and some of them like
Zara for example has flown us over to
their neck of the woods and we will show
them the videos I will say this is
exactly what this material comes from
it's not a materials not a natural fiber
it's it's from the animal it's stolen
from them they're killed for it they're
abused their suffering is atrocious it's
not sustainable that's one of the buzz
words now the humane washing words or
the environmental washing words it's not
sustainable cruelty shouldn't be
sustainable it's it's cruel or it's not
we've got Patagonia we've got all these
areas in Argentina where the sheep are
decimating the land and the people's
income should not be dependent on that
you can have other things you know we
didn't have to continue to grow tobacco
to sustain people's livelihoods so we go
and we sit down and we show them and
then we show them the alternatives and
we show them here's a Pho whatever it is
fleece will leather here's a range of
them and these are the you actually
bring in the samples we absolutely do we
like carpet salesman we have a portfolio
and it
got all these samples and we say here
are the contact names and addresses and
for these companies please get in touch
with them and there actually is a new
company now that has just started up
that is trying to and I forget the name
but it's it's on the website but it
started up trying to get investor money
to help these companies just the way
impossible and Berg beyond and all these
other colors good food institute you
mean bring what Bruce Friedreich's doing
it's a good food Institute for closers
and we're helping fund it at the moment
but it needs to have investor capital
uh-huh and what is the general level of
receptivity I would imagine clearance it
does vary I mean there's some old
holdouts but they've seen now what's
happened with fur you know there were
people who said we will always use fur
and they they don't anymore they had to
go with the times you look at Anna
Wintour at Vogue who was never seen on
the hottest summer day without : we
actually complained to the IRS that she
needed to declare all his free first she
was getting but just last week a week
before she was in a Stella McCartney
faux fur it's just phenomenal they know
now that times are changing consumer
interests are changing the next
generations up don't like cruelty to
animals they don't like the fact that if
you throw a fur coat out the window or
even a pair of leather shoes out the
window you can come back in a decade
they're still there because they have
been treated with morton's decon anti
decomposition chemicals so I'm still I'm
still stuck on Anna Wintour I'm
imagining her in her office in like 1994
like swearing about the thorn in her
side that is Ingrid Newkirk she was
actually because you know we invaded her
office yes he went up the elevator took
over her office she locked herself in
her office
we had begged her
had written her we'd shown her
everything heart of absolute ice and I
sat at the reception in vogue and
answered the phone and every single call
that came in they would ask for
something I'd say I'm awfully sorry
Vogue is closed today due to cruelty to
animals and the hen where was the
receptionist you just commandeered
everybody fled so what happened she had
to eventually come out of her office
eventually the police came and took us
out of the office and it got great news
and people heard our story about what
happens to animals and traps and further
have you had interactions with her since
yes but they haven't exactly been
pleasant one of our members
some years back threw a dead raccoon
into her soup plate when she was dining
at the Four Seasons Hotel and that was
in the news after that I was not the
best way to win her heart and mine but
you know we had tried everything
honest God it wasn't does it was a
member but people were angry with her
because she had seen all the footage she
she couldn't miss it and French Vogue
had decided they never French rogue of
all places had decided it would never
chauffeur and yet Anna Wintour's Vogue
carried on just really pimping fur in
almost every page so then she had a
birthday I think and I actually
suggested because there had been new
research that showed if you are
oblivious to suffering that perhaps it's
not your fault that your mirror neurons
might not be well developed that your
seat of empathy might not and I offered
to give her a free brain scan so he
could stop sending your letters begging
she did not reply oh my god well you
said we were provocative 100% 110% I it
seems to me that like when you look at
the food space the way to win the war is
to create plant-based analogues to
people's favorite meat and dairy
products make them cost-effective and
taste just as good if not better and I
think that applies as well in the
fashion context like you need the Stella
McCartney who can create something
beautiful and magical that isn't using
these materials to kind of lead the way
and once you do that if you can meet
Anna Wintour standards like then then
all the rest of the chips fall in line I
agree with meat and dairy week we call
them taster likes because you don't
really have to make an ethical decision
you can just have watched the taste that
you've perhaps grown up with or your
tongue has been become accustomed to
without any effort it's all there it's
in the store it doesn't cost more to
switch over to it the same is true with
clothing and what we're finding of
course is big companies now know that
they've got better sports gear if they
go away from the old animal I mean can
you imagine someone climbing Everest now
in a big fur coat so we those things
polyfill and all these things are
available too and that is changing the
market but yes I always have to be
pioneers it's like Joaquin Phoenix
standing up at the Oscars and saying I
mean that was a that was a watershed
moment absolutely he'd already veganized
what the Golden Globes and the other
award ceremonies up until that point and
then he stood there and he decided to
talk about Mother Love he decided to
talk about the love a mother cow has for
her child and how thoughtless it is to
just want a real cheese pizza topping
and I just thought I love you with all
my heart
a wonderful man who's a very courageous
bold and and beautifully honest and
heartfelt speech that he honest it was
honest and we are grown-ups aren't we I
mean that's what I say in the book is
it's time to come to grips with who we
are we tell our children that we're kind
we're decent that you know we live by
principles we don't like oppression
domination bullying in just
well do we because you can't pretend
that animals are tables and chairs
they're not they're intimate you know
anima from life is that they feel and
how awful if we don't behave like adults
and take personal responsibility hmm I
was really moved that Joaquin after the
SAG Awards left the ceremony and in his
tuxedo went straight to the pig vigil oh
it was and I know he does it all the
time he was there last night as well
he's a true activist and I mean you can
be an activist as I talk about now okay
you can be an activist just by deciding
well I eat three times a day at least
and now make sure that that doesn't
contribute or what I wear I shampoo my
hair whatever you do in the normal
course of your day but Joaquin is an
activist activist he's like James
Cromwell like a bunch of people Pamela
Anderson wherever she goes in the world
she calls us and she says what's
happening in Lithuania or wherever she
is for animals and we tell her and she
makes sure to do an action for animals
in addition to whatever else she's doing
there are only so many people and they
have such a command of people's
attention that each one is gold dust
each one is precious and he his heart
breaks for animals yeah it's it's it's
for real with him too the way through
when you look at the current state of
affairs I'm interested in how you choose
your battles right like if you if we
want to identify like the biggest
culprits the biggest problems I mean
factory farming seems to be number one
to me and it's also you're shaking your
head maybe you disagree but let me just
finish this thought in that also it's
it's it's a situation in which there's
massive popular support like nobody's
sitting around going yay for factory
farming like even Arden meat eaters
don't like that idea and it just seems
right to be reformed if not completely
overturned
innovation is working towards that but
I'm interested and where you kind of
come down with the work that PETA is
doing to combat the you know the tragic
ills and suffering that that system
creates there's no question animal based
agriculture has had its day it needs to
go the only people defending it really a
two camps the people who do it for a
living
the the farmers the factory farmers
themselves and their trade groups who
will defend it in fact a farmer was
addressing a conference a few years ago
and said if in grid' Newkirk were a cow
I'd have her on the truck right now
which I thought that's so nice I hope
you're single anyway yes so yeah there's
that but there's also I was just at the
Jimmy Carter Library in Atlanta and one
of the filmmakers for c-span said to me
I really don't like cruelty to animals
but you know I'm never going to give up
eating meat and so I said to him well
then you can't eat anything from a
supermarket you know you can't eat
anything whereas somebody didn't walk up
to that cow a pig or chicken shoot them
in the head when they weren't looking
and none of the other animals were
either you cannot do it and he was so
desperate to cling to this old habit
that that's another group that we have
to deal with but the way we figure out
what to do I think is where opportunists
because we have to see which way the
wind is blowing and then help push it in
the right direction so we give away food
we were down when KFC did they finger
lickin vegan chicken giveaway in Atlanta
and we've been working behind the scenes
with them and that will be coming we
give out food especially soy milk almond
milk and so on to kids who are lactose
intolerant show them you know there's
something else you can eat but we look
at where the largest animals suffer the
most and
violently that's in food production
don't have to eat animals please but the
second I think is experimentation
because there may be fewer animals and
that's not saying whew it's fewer but
they suffer sometimes for 40 years
in a cage in a room staring at the wall
with no life whatsoever someone taking
biopsies sticking things in their heads
taking their kids away all that that the
length of time is huge and clothing
because as I say every animal use for
clothing is eaten I can't think of an
exception even ostriches used for
feathers they're going to ostrich
medallions at the specialty exotic
restaurant crocodiles are eaten you know
all these animals are eaten so it's part
and parcel of its one profit base but we
also do look at exotic cruelties like
foie gras where you can say to people
it's like fur you don't need it why on
earth of all the things you cling to
would you decide I've got to have a
stuffed gooses liver for Christmas you
know that's got to be going the way of
fur though except in France and Austria
and a couple of other places but with
brexit you might be able to stop it from
being imported into the UK for example
and that's another nail in the coffin of
that I feel pretty much briefed on
everything that's kind of going on with
factory farming but the animal testing
world is something I know very little
about
so maybe illuminate the realities that
are going on here it's the same thing
with taste alikes really is that you've
got to move people away from what
they're used to and as with factory
farmers that's what they're doing and
they don't want to change you have
animal experimenters who have gone into
the business early they've been doing
the same thing for donkey's years no one
has ever tapped them on the shoulder and
said excuse me you're not finding out
anything but these animals are suffering
and you're killing them and so they
carry on doing it we have a system with
almost no enforcement in it at all and
I'll give you one example we have a
thing called the forced swim test this
is so absurd and so cruel they take
small animals drop them into a beaker of
water with solid sides and the animals
of course are panicked they are going to
drown they dive to the bottom looking
for a way out
they tries to scramble up the sides and
they can't get out and the whole purpose
this is used by universities as
show-and-tell it's used by
pharmaceutical companies is to just
document how many minutes it takes them
to give up to stop swimming and then you
just record this this is typical and we
are knocking that test for purpose what
is the purpose of that originally it was
some cockamamie crude way to decide when
an animal gets depressed too depressed
to carry on in the development of
depression t depression antidepressants
it still goes on and what we find is the
electric shock plate test in
universities with hanging animals by
their tails just to see how long they
stop struggling
we have maternal deprivation experiments
by psychologists millions upon millions
of dollars being spent all over the
country with people in basement labs who
are taking monkeys babies away and then
frightening them with plastic snakes
with plastic spiders with men and masks
and just recording their reaction this
goes on one experiment will go on for 40
years and nobody says maybe you
shouldn't be doing this anymore
we have organs on a chip human lungs a
heart on a chip we have whole slivers of
human brain you can grow in a petri dish
we have human DNA on the internet we
have high-speed computers you can
program now with human data you know
what are we doing still taking these
animals away from each other keeping
them unnaturally in total misery and
visiting all these horrors on them
what is the state of the law like what
is the law say change for forever most
animal experiments are exempt from
states law that happened a long time ago
and nobody really wants to change it
there are big trade groups that fight
they won't even expand the size of a
cage we've been up on Capitol Hill a
year after year I give up on legislation
I think it's as with most things it's
education and the new generations coming
up we have a film out now called
research subjects it's three women
happen to be women who were bullied into
using hundreds of animals in order to
get their PhDs and each one of them at
the time thought wait a minute this
isn't helping anyone
this isn't advancing my medical
knowledge this is just the way it's been
and each one of them not knowing of the
others try to argue with their
professors and their professor said no
no no you can't have your PhD unless you
do this this you have to do it they now
all regret it and other PhD candidates
are coming forward to say that's what
we've been told - it's the way it is in
research labs but times have moved on
and we are getting a force to be
reckoned with of a new generation of
scientists saying I don't want to be you
know keeping a chimpanzee or a monkey or
a rat in a small cage I want to be doing
something cutting-edge with science yeah
well it's not difficult for me to wrap
my head around how horrible it is that
an animal would be used to test
cosmetics or or you know antidepressants
and things like that is there I'm sure
you get crazy pushback here like is
there an is there any argument where
cutting-edge science and research
concerning
life-threatening diseases requires some
level of animal testing in order to
identify and and kind of find these
cures I think I'll give you a two-part
answer to that which may or may not be
satisfactory but the first part is it's
just as people
Kling to wanting to continue to eat meat
and dairy people somehow have this
uncomfortable feeling that they don't
like change
and they really cling to the idea that
surely somewhere there is some
experiment or a little raft of
experiments where you really do need to
eat animals or use animals and
experiments the same way people might
say but you know if you don't if you
really worry about your protein you
might need I think there's that there's
this clinging to the past which doesn't
really hold up and the other part we
have places we can go now we have things
we can do we need to push to take money
for example for years animals have been
used in burn experiments we have footage
where they actually blowtorch pigs and
the I mean it's not nice to look at
today because somebody back then decided
let's put some money into seeing if
there's another way to do that we have
cloned human skin we can ship it we can
Federal Express it we can put it on a
plane 80% of your body can be burned and
they can put cloned human skin on it we
didn't learn from those animal
experiments so the sooner we say I
demand that the government stop wasting
in one case alone 36 million dollars
frightening monkeys one single
experiments 36 million dollars and put
that 36 million dollars into something
innovative technology innovative
methodologies and we might get something
sooner
that will help human beings I think
those are the two things that we have to
work on who is working on that right now
is there is there activity around that
and also are there any bills that are
being sponsored right now to better
regulate what's happening we're working
on it we have 19 scientists and our
Peter science consortium and they're in
all kinds of disciplines and they
actually are working with governments
both here and in Holland in the UK in
Germany and in Japan in China even to
say look
times have changed here's something you
can do it's quicker
it's cheaper it's more expedient and it
doesn't cause animal suffering we just
in the last 12 months got the
Environmental Protection Agency to call
us into a news conference after years of
working with them going to their
symposia holding symposia ourselves
doing podcasts with them on alternatives
to say ok we now have a road map we are
going to step away we're going to stop
using animals in toxicity tests the
Environmental Protection Agency so it is
happening but it requires constant
vigilance and a constant push and really
it requires people to talk to their
members of Congress and say it's time
for a new research modernization act
which we have actually crafted and will
soon be having a news conference on
Capitol Hill about mmm that's great
hopefully yes I mean everything has to
change yeah as you're telling all these
stories I'm thinking that you're a very
interesting combination of passion you
know that that meets this kind of
abolitionist perspective that also
requires a tremendous amount of patience
and diplomacy right like how do you
reconcile those two things because in
order for you to do what you do and to
make incremental progress you have to do
this dance right where I don't know if
compromise is the right word but you've
got to work with people right and you
got to fan the flames of positive change
while also remaining true to your you
know your values that originated this
whole thing to begin with sometimes I'm
not a very patient person and as some
members of our staff will tell you I
have lost my temper and actually in the
case of Bobby Barris any orangutan act
where he used to beat them with a rebar
behind the scenes every night when
attorneys came to see us and said well
we're thinking of putting him back on
the stage I argued with him for a long
time tried to reason with him they
weren't buying it it was a money deal
and I threw the rebar across the table
at them and they decided okay then we
won't be doing that
no luckily on our staff we have
wonderful patient negotiators
strategists and so and we brainstorm a
lot but yes you do have to have patience
I definitely take comfort in looking
back otherwise I just couldn't carry on
to see how far we've come and to see
other take a leaf out of other movements
where they had to make hard decisions
every day is should we attack on this or
should we compromise on this and we like
to say we've got our heads and heads in
the clouds but our feet on the ground so
we want total abolition we don't want
any discrimination or disrespect for any
living being but we also if you can do
it a to B to C to D we'll work with you
because we want to get to Z yeah you
have to yeah absolutely you can't bleep
in most cases sometimes yes but you
can't usually leap from A to Z some of
the biggest wins have to be what's
happened with marine-life parks and with
the circuses and and even the zoos I
guess the summer to some extent yes
roadside zoos were busy closing and I
think we've got I'll tell you the wrong
figure probably but I believe it's 84
individual isolated bears out of those
places we've closed a lot down we've
taken out dozens of tigers and rehomed
them in wildlife parks that are
wonderful I think the end of the
roadside zoo is nigh zoos are changing
you've got the Detroit Zoo for example
where the director has said once these
elephants pass on we know we cannot deal
with the needs of elephants with its
zoos cannot so we're not going to do
that anymore we're closing the elephant
exhibit so we do see change there and we
do see some cooperation between the
better zoos which are not acquiring
anymore and I'm not doing research
anymore on animals in the basement
helping us close down the roadside zoos
we did just as you know get see.well to
stop writing
their trainers write on dolphins or
nostrums even still in business they're
changing and they need to change faster
because those workers and those dolphins
need to go back where they belong in the
oceans that they are they there are more
rides there they're doing concerts they
are diversifying now they just need to
get rid of that wretched name SeaWorld
on naked animatronic make it 3d
holograms of orcas not real orcas who
are losing their teeth trying to chew on
the underground underwater bars yeah one
of the arguments with zoos is that they
do do all of this kind of you know work
in terms of studying to better
understand these animals like we did
walk me through like the validity of any
of the arguments that kind of prop up
and support the kind of zoo
infrastructure as we know it big zoo
yeah well some of the worse news of
course engage in animal experiments
which are not good fertility experiments
and all sorts of things and that's not
something they make public so we do they
also some zoos have been caught getting
animals off the black-market endangered
species and so on we expose that to
other zoos as they say are changing and
they are actually helping get rid of the
worst zoos but I think they all see the
writing is on the wall and they see that
today kids don't really want to go to
the zoo they've got everything they
could possibly wish to have on the
internet if they can interact with
animals it can go under see and interact
with animals with virtual reality
without harming a hair on an animal's
head or a fin or anything else so yet
zoos started off and I talked about this
an animal kindly started off as
menageries where one of the saddest
things I've ever read was out of Africa
the author describes going down to the
docks I think it was Nairobi somewhere
and seeing giraffes
years ago who had been able to stride
across the Great Plains in these massive
herds and there are two of them on a
boat in a wooden crate
and saying their world has shrunk to
nothing now and they're going to be
taken across an ocean they've never seen
an ocean how frightening and they're
going to end up I think it was Hamburg
and end up in Germany in a zoo in a
small pen we still have zoos who cannot
in any way provide for one giraffe you
know they and they swap animals around
as if they're commodities that whole
system of seeing animals has to change
we did just have two judges one in
Brazil one in India who actually ruled
that in both cases elephants were not
commodities they couldn't be taxed like
property that they were refugees from
abuse is the most wonderful thing that's
the way I think law is going will go
takes a long time it takes a lot of
effort yeah I've noticed that young
people find zoos you know my daughter
like she doesn't like I've taken her to
a zoo and she's like I don't ever want
to go back there and that's not an
experience that I remember having as a
young person I think it speaks to a new
generation of people who who are just
who are just more conscious of these
things than we ever were in our younger
years you see the circus I mean when I
was a kid and that's going back but even
beyond then more recently than then the
circus came to town they would have the
elephants go down from the circus wagons
to the big top and actually help put the
big top up courtesy of a bull hook you
know that fireplace poker thing but kids
would go out line the streets so excited
to see exotic animals come to town right
there in front of them those days are
long gone
and of course we closed down Ringling
Brothers Barnum and Bailey what we would
call the cruelest circus on earth for
awful cruelties behind the scenes I
don't think people even know they burned
a lion to death going through the Mojave
Desert
they had three baby elephants in
separate incidents killed during
training they should never have been
away from their mothers so if you
all the learning about the stuff they
now know what a bull hook is and they're
saying no to circuses I think the time
of deciding that wild animals are props
for us is not something young people
think of they think oh they're wonderful
look how they live how intelligent they
are look at their lives in the wild
they're incredible nests if you will
yeah and how do you think about the pet
trade badly
I mean look our shelters are overflowing
we've got dogs cats even bunnies with
nowhere to go they're going to be put
down because no matter how hard you try
there aren't enough good homes to go
around and so how can we ever support
somebody somewhere having a puppy mill
farm and shipping in puppies to be sold
in glass cages and a shot or you know
going to a breeder we always say adopt
don't shop and even people who you
ordinarily wouldn't associate with
understanding this concept seem to get
it now but so many people are still
buying and no pet shops are actually the
reverse of what we should be doing
they're putting more animals on the
market
we need to spay and neuter number-one
thing cut it off at the pass
answer prevention and then secondly
always adopt never shut don't go to a
breeder don't go to a pet shop close
them down yeah well I think I think
education has gone a long way towards
towards moving that needle it has but
then again there's such frustration when
you see how many people have French
bulldogs pugs there was just the
Westminster Dog Show you know what is
that but contrived breeds that humans
have made with squashed faces with
dysplastic hips with all these physical
problems that will cost you a lot of
money if nothing else and they're not
you know the homeless heartiest animals
will just not to mention the entire
strangeness of that whole
you know parading these dogs around for
some kind of prize yeah one of the
things that I see going on right now is
there's a tremendous amount of energy
that goes into greenwashing because
people are more aware and they do want
to feel like they're making the
conscious ethical choice and yet there
is so much energy and money behind
marketing products in a way that's
dishonest and disingenuous to make
people feel like they're making that
right choice when they actually aren't
absolutely and now this humane washing
magnetically treated animals that
they're ethically ray all these sort of
terms that get phrase that gets thrown
around that aren't they're not really
regulated or legally defined terms
they're just loosely you know
constructed marketing phrases rubbish I
would say it's so easy if you really
care and so many people do care is just
don't buy anything that comes from an
animal because either the animal gave up
their life for it or they're kept in
confinement for years and years or it
was stolen from them and they needed it
I go up to people in the grocery store
for example because I see them if
they've got a package of eggs you'll see
this green grass on the eggs and it says
free-range organic and I say excuse me I
noticed you're buying those I'm sure
that means that you care about getting
away from Cruelty to Animals and they'll
say yes always and I say well let me
just tell you if you go to the PETA
website you will see what a fraud this
is because places like Nellie's eggs
we've been inside their sheds and
Nellie's eggs we're suing them right now
there's a class-action suit how dare you
tell consumers they're humanely produce
these hens have less than the size of
this book to stand in they're crammed
together they have no pecking order and
they say oh well they can go outside
they can if they can fight their way to
that little hole that you've cut at
several spaces in
you know hugely crowded shared and
chickens are afraid and if they do go
out because it's open and it's closed at
night it's closed in winter it's closed
if it's raining they will find probably
a space not that much bigger than this
desk that's just a bit of mud so no stop
lying to consumers just don't buy
anything that's what's the reaction that
you get Oh I don't tell people all that
I just say go and look at the video and
this is basically said and people are
usually grateful and we actually have
filmed consumers coming out of the
grocery store and asked them hey you've
got this organic sustainable free-range
eggs let me show you video we show them
a little bit of video and without
exception everyone goes oh my god I had
no idea well I'll never buy those again
well really I thought yeah consumer
fraud if you ask me yeah yeah yeah yeah
I I think that that uh there's a lot of
opportunity also with respect to to
dairy and and with and with respect to
wall because those are things that I
think the average kind of less than
informed consumer just can feel like
well I'm not killing the animal like I'm
using their product but you know they're
they're treated fine and there aren't a
farm somewhere bless your heart for
saying that the two things are well it's
just a haircut isn't it for sheep and
say if you saw the video footage you
would know and I've been to Australia
where most of the wool in this country
comes from and I've seen them cut to
shreds and they didn't think anything of
it I was there because they also take
the Lambs and cut the flesh off the
backs of the Lambs and a thing that's
called mule zing that they've been doing
since 1920 I was there to argue them on
that we didn't think anything of the
shearing sheds and so they just walked
me through and the shearing sheds the
sheep are just trembling from head to
foot they've been cut to pieces
sometimes they've lost a teat or a part
of the site of their ear or something
because the Nano working so quickly
they're paid the most they
can do so nobody takes any care but the
other thing is dairy is that people will
say and I said it too is they don't kill
the cow for dairy but of course where is
this retirement home for all these dairy
cows there isn't one yes they do they
kick her and shove her down the same
ramp that the circle beef cow goes down
but when she's in the worst possible
shape she's dried up what she's got
mastitis and along the way is far
crueler than beef because they've taken
her beloved baby away every time for
veal or whatever they've done so no
where are the current biggest battle
fields like what is where is PETA
investing its energy at the moment
unfortunately we don't have the luxury
of homing in on one honing in on one
place we have food clothing
experimentation pest control is another
one why do we use gut wrenching poisons
sticky glue traps and so on if we want
to get rid of animals who are here first
but we now find it inconvenient there is
animals in entertainment which as you
say it's just you know it's going away
we just have to push it over the cliff
but experimentation is a number-one push
because that really needs an awakening
in the same way that we've woken up to
the enormous waste and suffering that
goes into meat and dairy production yeah
I think you know just from my own
experience like that's the area I know
the least amount of least about and I
feel like that's an area where you know
some education could really be
beneficial to people we've mostly
knocked out cosmetics testing on animals
when Peter started I think there was one
company that she could import something
from France it was called not sure to
France you could get a soap and so on
then there were five companies one was
in Berkeley you had to take care of
bottle and get things filled up and now
we've got it we're going back to that by
the way now they're stores that they're
like their whole marketing thing is that
you bring your own bottle
but that's for a good another good
reason but no you can just go in the
store we just got suave and Herbal
Essences the two of the last big
holdouts they no longer test on animals
and we've just got China to adopt its
very first non animal test China was a
big holder so cosmetics now it's
research for research sake basic just in
quiz inquisitiveness curiosity driven
research and his old-fashioned
show-and-tell research and its medical
so-called medical research a lot of
psychology mental health issues
I mean people can't get into mental
health clinics they can't get into drug
treatment programs and yet we are giving
drugs to animals for decades all over
the country we are giving them mental
illness we are causing them enormous
suffering and there is no applicability
at all is there any country has its
ethical barometer perfectly calibrated
to your worldview like is there any like
is there a model out there where there's
a nation that has a regulatory landscape
and a legal system that that is
protecting animals far better than we
are
I'm not saying perfect but is there a
you know like is there a model that we
can look to and at least work our way
towards I think different countries do
much better than we do in different
areas for example Holland is definitely
moving away from the use of animals and
experimentation faster than we are you
have countries like Switzerland where
it's I don't believe it's legal anymore
to keep a goldfish in a bowl because
they have to have so much surface area
and they're not props they're not
decorations you have countries in Europe
where you can actually you're required
to walk your dog three times a day and
not just pretend that you know you're
just going out to do your business and
come home you have to take them for a
proper walk because that's their they
have a life chance the law not to walk
your dog correct I love that
certain number of times for a certain
number of minutes we do have an T
slaughter laws against some animals in
India but that's mostly for religious
reasons it really depends where you are
different countries different things
yeah yeah yeah and if somebody's
listening to this I mean if you go with
respect to the food like you know I
think people are kind of up to speed you
go to most markets now they have vegan
options everything's labeled and it's
it's easier than ever to kind of make
those decisions but a little bit harder
with cosmetics and consumer products
I mean leather we can stay away from but
you know there's a lot of glues that are
used in in clothing and and and it's
difficult even for a well-intentioned
somewhat educated consumer to even know
what they're buying right where are the
resources where people can go to learn a
little bit more about this yeah and I'm
not really worried I mean this may sound
odd but I'm not really worried about the
purism if you will of looking at every
single thing because we've got a long
way to go and we need to move the market
with the big things at the moment
leather wool those kinds of things dairy
let's move them out we do have huge
resources animal kind the book I've got
resources in it Peter org resources we
have a lists of cruelty-free companies
and lists of companies that still test
on animals we have health charities for
example you can give money because you
care about certain let's take birth
defects Easter Seals they still use
animals and experiments get away from it
you can give your money to another
charity instead so you can we have those
health charity lists we have the
cosmetics list we have the clothing
lists foodless you name it yeah when you
began this the entry point like the
on-ramp was simply an ethical argument
about the treatment of animals but now
we have people who are coming into this
because of their current concerns about
health I mean that was my introduction
to this whole thing and and now the
environment
I think has become a really huge point
of interest for people that's bringing
more and more people into this so the
spectrum of of you know everything that
you're doing has now broadened
tremendously from from when you began
it's true we still have a long way to go
of course and I am fond of telling
people you can fly from Los Angeles to
London and back to Los Angeles and you
still haven't made the carbon footprint
that you would have if you had two boxes
of chicken nuggets and people are amazed
they think oh it's flying you know so we
still have a lot of Education to do a
lot of people say oh it's so expensive
to be vegan it actually isn't at all I
mean you look at cultures like Mexico
and so on beans rice salsa pasta yeah
fabulous food for you greens you know
whatever so there's still a lot of
education but I think that generations
growing up have their eyes open wider I
think they're more open to the
compassion aspect of it and they're
going to teach the adults they always do
don't they they do it is interesting
what you said about purity the purity
argument there is a there is a strain of
Puritanism that that kind of you know
underscores a large cross-section of the
vegan community and I think that's
important
somebody has to like hold that line and
let us know where it is but it also
works across purposes I think with
bringing people in and I remember like
Lisa sitting over here like I met Lisa
years ago she came here with a film crew
to do an interview with me and this was
pretty early on in my you know evolution
as a vegan
you know plant-based person and at the
time I think we had like a cowhide rug
that we just had forever and maybe a
leather cow and I was like we got to get
rid of this stuff before Lisa comes over
here because I don't want to get shamed
and like how does this work and like I
didn't know the landscape or the
rulebook about what's okay and what's
not and I had a fear of that strain of
Puritanism you know you know being
directed in my direction even though
like I had kind of
jumped the fence and was learning as I
was going and I've certainly progressed
and evolved since that moment but I
think that's something that that I think
it's common among people and I know a
lot there's a listen there's a lot of
vegan people that listen this podcast
was a lot of people that aren't and I
think the just the sheer idea of Ingrid
Newkirk coming on the podcast and
sharing their her message it's like oh
man like I don't you know I don't want
to be you know I don't want to be judged
for not being you know on this side of
the fence or as far along in my
evolution here so well I was the
ultimate slow learner I had my first fur
coat at 19 I fished and it's funny
because back then I would go along the
pier and say to people who are fishing
you need to cut the spine because
that'll stop them from feeling pain you
know you need to stop fishing I don't
believe that it's about personal purity
it's like some people will take yoga
it's just for health there's a spiritual
aspect to it there's an ethical aspect
to why we don't hurt animals as a moral
aspect there's a decency aspect so it's
good to point out to people that
actually that came from suffering or if
there's an alternative to that other
thing or you can be compassionate and
you're being unwittingly cruel but to do
it in a nice way
I'm always trying first to negotiate
because I remember I was defensive when
someone said something to me even about
spaying my cat back then I didn't know
why you should spare your cat and I'm so
glad someone told me about factory farms
told me about fur I had experiences that
opened my eyes so do you think we have
the obligation to educate but not be
condemnatory because we're all learning
and then if people really don't budge
then I think you should be sharper with
them and say oh come on you can do that
here I'll feed you here I'll show you
this let me take you out and show you
this especially if they're family or
friends
all right so where do you see PETA in
the future and this movement like if it
was up to you what is this what is this
utopian world look like paint the
picture well like land this plane I I'm
not very good at crystal balling things
and I live day to day because we've got
so much going on and so many things that
we have you're not retiring anytime soon
no by a factory farmer but no I mean
this is my life and this is what I want
to do and I don't want to be on my
deathbed thinking I should have said
something I should have done something I
could do better I wish I was smarter but
I want to do as much as I can and I
think Peter has that mindset at all our
founding members have it all our people
have it is that we want to get the job
done and we know it's going to be a long
job so we'll never have world peace
we'll have never have the end of child
abuse you know but people work to get as
much of it out of the way as possible
and that's that's us yeah we need
everybody with us there really is a very
thin line between your life and your
vocation like these are this this is who
you are through and through absolutely
can't separate what you do from who you
are
that is a very lucky thing right to be
able to ply your passion and live this
purposeful life that has meaning and and
in so doing really change the world and
you have it's it's remarkable the legacy
of your career and I commend you for
that thank you it's only because people
have come on board it's only because
we've said your power of the purse
counts your activism counts I try to do
five things every day what I would call
outside my job and that is one of those
footing you can start a kits in the back
of the airplane inside the magazines on
all the seats before anybody comes in if
I can I like a secret agent talking to
the people at the desk
removing the seaworld pamphlets from the
hotel
because nobody needs to be enticed to go
there until they change their stripes
I'm talking to people is just suggesting
something speaking to the person at the
checkout mentioning vegan foods or
clothing complimenting something on
something saying oh that looks as if
that's whatever it's just working yeah
well thank you for the service that you
do oh thank you for the animals and for
humanity you are a gift and I'm in awe
of your commitment to service it's
really a beautiful thing and the world
is a better place for having you in it
so thank you you're very kind
thank you yeah the book is animal kind
you can find it everywhere support your
favorite independent bookseller and if
you can't do that you can find it on
Amazon you worked with gene stone on
this book who I know well he's a
wonderful man great guy he did a great
job with the book I really enjoyed it so
thank you and I wish you health so you
can continue to do the work that you do
I wish that too you too and everyone
listening very cool so if people want to
learn more about you and the work that
PETA is doing PETA org and you're easy
to find on the Internet yes and please
let us help you if you want to
transition in any way we are there for
you cool thank you
peace implants
[Music]
you